- Was brauchen wir noch?
- Wir müssen die Ballpumpe
noch mitnehmen!
- Hab' ich schon.
- Und die Fußbälle.
- Sie liegen hinter dir.
- Oh!
- Ich hab' zwei neue gekauft
und Würste zum Grillen,
Getränke und Hütchen
zum Trainieren.
- Toll! Waren die Fußbälle teuer?
- Nein, die waren superbillig.
Ein Ball hat 4,99 Euro gekostet,
weniger als die Getränke.
- Tja, Verpflegung ist
immer am teuersten.
Hey, Nico. Bist du bereit?
- Na ja, ich hab' keine Fußballschuhe
mit, aber es geht schon.
- Welche Schuhgröße hast du?
- Äh?
- Warte! Warte!
- Hey, nicht schlecht.
Du bist ja viel zu gut für uns.
- Probier die mal.
Eins, zwei …
- Pflaster und Verbände.
Irgendeiner verletzt sich immer.
Tarek hat sich beim letzten Mal
am Knie verletzt.
- Ich konnte zwei Tage nicht laufen.
- Die Schuhe passen. Vielen Dank!
- Perfekt!
Ich finde es super, dass du mitkommst!
- Es geht los!